La mia terra di fiabe e magie credi a me ha i cammelli che van su e giù
brilla il sole da sud soffia il vento da nord c'è un'intensa
complicità
sul tappeto ora va dove andare lo sa nelle notti d'oriente andrà
scappa un pezzo di pane bada
che sono già qua rubo solo quel che servirà
cioè tutto
ladro cane molla il pane
solo uno spuntino
ti squartiamo giú il bottino che malvagità non c'é carità sei il mio solo amico Abu
na na na na naa
chiedi pure tutto ciò che vuoi ad un amico  amico come me
Sono d'oro i suoi mille cammelli
e i pavoni color viola e blu
Le sue bestie sono veri
gioielli
che cos'è uno zoo beh io lo so é un serraglio di sangue blu
Grande Alí principe Alí Alí Ababua
faccia in giù sempre più in giù con umiltà
Se il posto non perderai in prima fila sarai
é uno spettacolo che mai piú tornerà
Ogni cosa che ho
Anche quella più bella
No non vale la stella che fra poco toccheró il mondo é mio
apri gli occhi e vedrai fra mille diamanti voleró la tua notte piú bella
con un pó di follia e di magia
è un mondo che appartiene a noi
Soltanto a noi per me e per te
ci aiuterà non svanirà solo per noi solo per noi
per te e per me